[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
guten abend wir schreiben tag 8 des
krieges ein krieg sven forster auch den
internationalen sport weiter betrifft ja
und das betrifft auch die paralympics in
peking morgen beginnen mehr dazu im
sport es gibt weiter massive gefechte
erbitterten widerstand und historische
fluchtbewegungen da sind die neuesten
entwicklungen über die wiese heute
informieren möchten
auch heute gab es wieder bombenangriffe
auf wohngebiete
russland zielt auf mehrere städte trifft
häuser schulen einkaufszentren die
ukraine spricht von kriegsverbrechen
währenddessen prüft die bundesregierung
weitere waffen an die ukraine zu liefern
es geht vor allem um panzerabwehrraketen
aus alten ddr beständen und etwa eine
million menschen sind bereits vor dem
krieg geflohen und suchen in europa
schutz und sicherheit
entgegen anfänglicher beteuerungen man
wolle keine zivilen ziele angreifen
attackiert das russische militär genau
diese von russlands präsident putin gab
es vor einer stunde ans eigene volk
gerichtet durchhalteparolen garniert mit
neuen vorwürfen richtung westen heftige
russische attacken gibt es im osten gibt
es im norden christoph destor l und
markus kübler beginnen ihren beitrag mit
berichten über dauerbeschuss und
dramatische hilferuf im süden
mario pohl und reaktion zwei städte im
süden am meer was dort gerade passiert
dazu erreichen uns fast keine bilder nur
verzweifelte schwer überprüfbare
hilferufe per twitter diese aus mario
pohl das hier ist das einkaufscenter in
meiner nähe wir haben keinen strom kein
wasser sind abgeschnitten humanitäre
katastrophe völkermord ich habe keine
worte
ein video schnipsel im internet zeigt
den ausgebrannten supermarkt noch ein
zweiter sei zerstört worden heißt es
offenbar wurden gezielt die essens
reserven bombardiert
440.000 einwohner unter dauerbeschuss 14
stunden am stück und ein fassungsloser
bürgermeister
liebe mitbürger von mario pohl heute war
der härteste und brutalste tag dieses
krieges bis jetzt sie wollen uns einfach
nur alle zerstören
anderseits in mariupol scheint der
militärische widerstand intrexx
eingebrochen fast 300.000 einwohner und
die ukrainische armee abgezogen
stattdessen sollen russische panzer in
den strassen ein einwohner berichtet
die panzer stehen vor meinem fenster
vielleicht zehn meter entfernt soldaten
feuerten warnschüsse ab und sagen uns
zivilisten dass wir nicht mehr vor die
tür dürfen
und dann noch diese aufnahmen aus dem
süden die nichts gutes ahnen lassen
russische kriegs und landungsschiffe
liegen vor dessau eine millionenstadt
wappnet sich für den wohl bevorstehenden
großangriff genau wie skf tut
doch der russische militärkonvoi im
norden der hauptstadt von dem so viel
die rede war kommt nicht voran
ukrainische gegenwehr staus und pannen
hätten ihn 30 kilometer vor dem
stadtrand vorerst ausgebremst glaubt der
britische geheimdienst twitter bilder
wie dieses könnte ein beleg dafür sein
manche kleinstadt umkehr warum ist aber
schon bis ins mark getroffen
borodjanka 60 kilometer vor kiew im
zentrum ein einziges trümmerfeld tote
und verletzte unklar beschwörend redet
der ukrainische präsident auf die
russischen soldaten ein
geht nach hause nehmt eure armee mit
sagt euren kommandeur dass er nicht
sterben volt sondern leben
doch die zerstörung der ukraine geht
weiter
bei in cardiff im nordosten von kiew
seit beginn der kämpfe fallen hier
bomben mitten in die wohngebiete sieben
tage krieg heißt für die betreuung der
hochschwangeren der stadt sieben tage
geburten hilfe im bunker 46 babys kam so
schon zur welt und
wir gehen jetzt live zu unserer
reporterin katrin eigendorf sie ist
westlich von der hauptstadt kiew in der
stadt metz ki.ka kathrin es gab wieder
gespräche zwischen der ukraine und
russland es ging dabei auch darum
korridore zu schaffen für humanitäre
hilfe und zivilisten was können sie uns
dazu sagen und wie ist die situation bei
ihnen
also wir hören gerade auf der
ukrainischen delegation das eigentlich
die minimalforderungen die ja die
ukrainische regierung hatte zumindest
humanitäre korridore zu schaffen und
einen waffenstillstand einen vorläufigen
zu vereinbaren nicht mal erfüllt worden
dass man auch da nicht weitergekommen
ist man will aber in die dritte runde
der verhandlungen gehen das heißt da ist
keine bewegung reingekommen und es gibt
auch keine anzeichen dass putin diesen
krieg in irgendeiner form stoppen will
ganz im gegenteil je härter die
sanktionen sind und die entschlossener
die ukraine hier widerstand leisten und
je mehr der westen auch zusammen steht
desto grausamer und brutaler geht putin
hier vor und das macht sich mittlerweile
auch hier bei uns bemerkbar
wir sind zwar noch nicht in einem
kriegszustand aber die menschen gehen
auch hier aus der stadt vermehrt raus
weil sie angst haben der krieg kann auch
hierhin kommen im prinzip ist kein ort
der ukraine mehr wirklich wirklich
sicher und die meisten menschen haben
einfach jetzt angst dass dieser krieg so
bald nicht enden wird dass er immer
brutaler wird und dass putin weiter
eskalieren wird live aus der ukraine
katrin eigendorf dankeschön
russlands präsident hat sich vor
ungefähr einer stunde in einer
fernsehansprache zu wort gemeldet wieder
mit vorwürfen gegen die ukraine aber
auch mit versprechungen für die
angehörigen russischer soldaten
die russischen streitkräfte und aus dem
bombast kämpfen wie echte helden sie
sind standhaft und bleiben sogar nach
einer verletzung in der truppe sie
opfern sich selbst und ihr leben um
kameraden zu retten
für unsere soldaten versuchen und taten
nicht zuzulassen und erleiden leider
erhebliche verluste
die familien und angehörigen von den
gefallenen werden entschädigt auch mit
monatlichen zahlungen
unsere armee kämpft für die
entnazifizierung und entmilitarisierung
der ukraine dafür dass kein anti
russland entsteht das seit jahren an
unserer grenze aufgebaut wird
das lassen wir uns einordnen von
christian sam in moskau christian die
rede von putin war vor allem adressiert
an die eigenen landsleute welche
botschaft geht also von diesem auftritt
aus
ja genau dieser fernsehansprache die war
vor allem nach innen gerichtet putin hat
noch einmal betont wie wichtig dieser
einsatz ist wie wichtig dieser kampf ist
und was bemerkenswert ist dass er doch
so offen über die russischen opfer
geredet hat das hat man ja die ganze
zeit vermieden gestern gab es dann
erstmals eine zahl
498 die ukrainische seite die geht von
vielmehr russischen opfern aus da
kursiert eine zahl von 9000 wie hoch die
zahl genau ist wissen wir nicht aber das
putin öffentlich darüber spricht es
bemerkenswert auch dass er von
entschädigungszahlungen spricht die
sollen in der höhe von rund 7 millionen
rubel legen das sind umgerechnet so
62.000 euro also eine menge geld und ich
glaube es ist ein zeichen erstmal dieser
auftritt dass es nicht rund läuft dass
es nicht so läuft wie putin sich das
vorgestellt hat und er will mit dieser
ankündigung der zahlung auch zeigen dass
die kriegskasse gut gefüllt ist und dass
man sich das durchaus leisten kann und
dass die opferzahlen eben doch nicht so
hoch sind wie die ukraine das behauptet
christian vielen dank nach moskau wir
wollen direkt weitergeben nach paris um
mit thomas walde zu sprechen thomas
frankreichs präsident marco ist so
ziemlich der einzige westliche
staatschefs der noch einen direkten
draht zu putin hat die beiden haben
heute über eine stunde telefoniert mit
welchem ergebnis
nach diesem telefonat haben sich sowohl
der kreml wie auch der élysée geäußert
demnach hat es keinerlei annäherung
gegeben putin habe sich zu seinen zielen
bekannt habe die noch einmal bekräftigt
auch mit dem vokabular dass wir eben
gehört haben in seinen worten
entmilitarisierung entnazifizierung und
er meint das sei auf einem guten weg
diese ziele auch zu erreichen
präsident marco hat ihnen vorgehalten zu
lügen russland werde so makro einen
hohen preis bezahlen für diese angriffe
die sanktionen würden noch sehr lange
aufrechterhalten marco hat sich nach dem
telefonat pessimistisch gezeigt die
schwersten tage stünden noch bevor putin
wolle ganz offensichtlich die gesamte
ukraine unterwerfen gleichwohl wolle der
élysée wolle frankreich seine
diplomatischen bemühungen fortsetzen
danke nach paris thomas walde
für alle in der ukraine und die
geflüchteten ist es eine sehr schwere
zeit neben den politischen
hilfsangeboten gibt es auch in der
deutschen bevölkerung eine große
unterstützung und spendenbereitschaft
aber kommen die hilfsgüter wirklich bei
den betroffenen an das wollte mein
kollege armin coerper wissen der in der
west ukraine unterwegs war
wir sind unterwegs im westen der ukraine
immer wieder checkpoint doch wir kommen
durch wir wollen wissen was mit den
vielen hilfslieferungen passiert auch
mit denen aus deutschland die sind hier
ukraine hilfe berlin steht auf der kiste
in polen wurden sie verladen über die
grenze gebracht und liegen jetzt in
dieser lagerhalle windeln wasser
schlafsäcke schuhe pack tatiana sie
kommt jeden tag hierher wir sind so
dankbar für eure hilfe es sind so
schwere zeiten für uns
früher durften wir nicht mal zigaretten
über die grenze bringen und jetzt sehen
sie doch selbst es muss umgepackt werden
damit die richtigen güter an die
richtigen bedürftigen kommen irgendwo im
zentrum süden und osten des riesigen
landes das am abgrund steht wir brauchen
lebensmittel das ist das größte problem
vor allem für babys
denn viele mütter haben auf der flucht
einem solchen schock erlitten dass sie
nicht mehr stillen können auch
medikamente kommen aus deutschland
manches geht an verwundete soldaten
wir brauchen verbandsmaterial krücken so
viel wir sind allen dankbar die helfen
gerade hier im westen des landes gibt es
zahlreiche solcher verteilungszentren
für hilfsgüter die dezentralisierung hat
vor allem sicherheitsgründe denn die
angst ist groß dass auch solche orte zu
zielen russischer luftangriffe werden
könnten
zum abschied singen sie für uns
[Musik]
die nationalhymne eines landes das die
welt in diesen tagen beeindruckt mit
seinem kampf ums überleben
sie wissen der krieg in der ukraine hat
deutschlands sicherheitspolitik radikal
verändert nachdem kanzler scholz am
sonntag die lieferung von panzer- und
flugabwehrraketen verkündete wurde heute
morgen bekannt dass weitere abwehrwaffen
aus alten nva beständen geliefert werden
sollen über den kurswechsel und die
reaktionen ines trams
alt sind sie derzeit lagern sie in
verschimmelten kisten verschrotten
wollte man sie die strehler
flugabwehrraketen der nva hier
archivbilder nun sollen sie an die
ukraine gehen der wirtschaftsminister
begründet ist ganz einfach die ukraine
sei schließlich im krieg wir haben uns
entschieden die selbstverteidigung der
ukraine nach diesem eklatanten bruch der
völker des völkerrechts und das recht
auf selbstverteidigung auch militärisch
zu unterstützen indem wir waffen liefern
bereits zuvor hatte die bundesregierung
eingewilligt panzerfäuste zu liefern und
stinger boden-luft-raketen nachdem lange
gegolten hatte keine waffen in
krisengebiete spät kommen sie nun doch
sie könnten den luftraum über der
ukraine absichern helfen selbst wenn die
raketen nicht einfach zu bedienen sind
oder vielleicht nicht so zielgenau sind
ist es trotzdem eine zusätzliche gefahr
für die russischen streitkräfte die
dadurch entsteht es führt zu einer
zusätzlichen verlangsamt zu weniger
freiheit in der bewegung mit seinem
besuch in litauen heute will
bundespräsident steinmeier bündnis
solidarität ohne wenn und aber wie er
sagt untermauern deutschland hat mit
waffenlieferungen zur unterstützung der
ukraine bei der selbstverteidigung einen
großen schritt gemacht und sich und mit
manchen alten gewissheiten gebrochen ein
paradigmenwechsel der von den ampel
parteien auch von grünen und spd unter
dem druck der ereignisse mitgetragen
wird unsere welt ist steht in großer
gefahr unsere westliche welt unsere
unsere wertegemeinschaft und deswegen
ist auch es notwendig dass wir an der
stelle mit bisherigen maximen brechen
angesichts der eskalierenden lage
fordert der ukrainische botschafter
heute von der deutschen regierung
erstmals nun auch waffen die nicht als
reine defensivwaffen gelten dann glauben
wir schon dass auch unsere bitte
gerechtfertig ist dass uns auch panzer
gepanzerte wagen aber auch vielleicht
flugzeuge drohnen und anderes
kriegsgerät geliefert wird eine
kehrtwende der deutschen außenpolitik
offen allerdings ob diese neuen wünsche
der ukraine erfüllt werden
ja was deutschland in dieser krise tun
kann darum geht es heute abend bei
maybrit illner sie spricht ab würden 18
mit ihrem einzigen gast mit
bundeskanzler olaf scholz
unbürokratische und schnelle hilfe für
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine für
mindestens ein jahr bekommen sie
sozialhilfe und eine arbeitserlaubnis
das haben heute die eu-innenminister auf
den weg gebracht die zahl der
flüchtlinge hat laut uno jetzt eine
million erreicht mehr als die hälfte von
ihnen sucht im nachbarland polen schutz
aber auch in ungarn sind es mehr als
100.000 deutschland registriert etwa
9500 kriegsflüchtlinge das sind
zumindest die offiziellen zahlen über
die einigung aus brüssel ina baltes
schlagbaum auf der weg in die eu ist
frei 100.000 frauen und kinder fliehen
allein gestern hier in medica über die
ukrainisch polnischen grenze kein
asylantrag es reicht allein der pass
unverzüglich und unbürokratisch so will
es die eu sollen die ukraine einen
schutz finden
wir können uns nur bei euch bedanken
dass wir kommen dürfen wir werden hier
von guten menschen empfangen das berührt
unsere seele ich kann einfach nicht mehr
in brüssel einigen sich die 27 eu
innenminister in auf einen schutzstatus
für ukraine und menschen die dort legal
leben sie alle dürfen damit in der eu in
die schule arbeiten oder bekommen
sozialhilfe erst einmal gilt das für ein
jahr es herrscht große einigkeit auch
unter denen die sich früher massiv gegen
eine gemeinsame flüchtlingspolitik
gewährt hatten
das ist ein bisschen ein
paradigmenwechsel der war gut ist und
ich hoffe dass diese humanität auch
beibehalten wird ein
verteilungsschlüssel wird es nicht geben
jeder geflüchtete darf in das land
seiner wahl polen nimmt bisher die
meisten auf und soll finanzielle
unterstützung bekommen mehr als eine
millionen haben es schon über die grenze
geschafft erwartet so die eu heute
werden noch über fünf millionen weitere
flüchtlinge
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und den geflüchteten helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das
stichwort heißt zdf nothilfe ukraine
alle infos auch auf spenden zdf de oder
im zdf text auf der seite 890
an vielen schulen wird inzwischen über
den krieg informiert das ist keine
einfache situation weder für schüler
noch für lehrkräfte und in zeiten wo
fast alle jugendlichen einen großen teil
ihrer zeit online verbringen ist
natürlich auch klar dass sie dort
ebenfalls auf schlimme und schockierende
kriegs bilder und videos treffen können
was macht das mit ihnen wie gehen sie
damit um markus wolsiffer berichtet für
uns aus hessen wie konnte es soweit
kommen warum herrscht krieg in europa
für die schüler der humboldt schule in
wiesbaden sind das brennende fragen in
ihren klassen sprechen sie täglich
darüber und viele äußern angst fühlen
sich überfordert in diesen tagen
das jetzt in auf der welt wieder ein
krieg ist und
das ist einfach unvorstellbar und ich
finde das auch sehr schlimm
und ich brauch wurde es nicht bei uns
jetzt ist haben auch gedacht hier so
handy mal vielleicht wissen weg legen
sich davon zu distanzieren weil
dauerhaft darauf zu gucken weil sich
dann auch nicht ob das am ende gut und
gesund dann auch noch ist in der
humboldtschule haben einige schüler
russische und ukrainische wurzeln auf
einmal ist der krieg ganz nah die lehrer
versuchen auf die vielen ängste
einzugehen den komplizierten konflikt
irgendwie einzuordnen doch für die
schule sei die situation schlimmer als
corona es je war sagt der
stellvertretende schulleiter wir haben
auch keine zeit gehabt das in
irgendeiner weise darauf vorzubereiten
ich glaube keiner hat geglaubt dass
putin so schnell und so brutal in der
ukraine zuschlägt und ja wir gucken und
einem schock im augenblick und wir
versuchen uns langsam daraus zu arbeiten
experten appellieren auch an die eltern
über den krieg mit ihren kindern zu
sprechen jedoch ohne zu tabuisieren rät
die kinder- und jugendpsychologin
claudia calmano nicht sagen da ist
nichts das ist alles nicht schlimm das
passiert alles gar nicht sondern einfach
auch eine offenheit signalisieren
gesprächsbereitschaft
signalisieren und über diese bilder auch
sprechen darüber sprechen was da gerade
passiert
die schüler und lehrer der
humboldtschule wollen weiter über den
krieg reden aber auch etwas tun sie
planen eine spendenaktion und schon bald
wollen sie hilfspakete schicken als
zeichen europäischer solidarität
die angst vor den folgen des
klimawandels hat sie auf die straßen
getrieben jetzt ist es auch die angst
vor dem krieg zehntausende junge fridays
for future demonstranten haben in
mehreren deutschen städten protestiert
um solidarität zu zeigen und um die
klimawende einzufordern denn nur so
könne deutschland wirklich unabhängig
von russischer energie werden ralf
zimmermann von siewert
allein auf hamburgs straßen waren ist
heute zehntausende junger menschen die
klimaaktivisten sehen sich dabei in
großer solidarität mit den menschen in
der ukraine die antwort auf diesen krieg
muss zum einen natürlich die absolute
sofortige hilfe für die ukraine sein
aber es muss eben auch ein radikaler
ausstieg aus den fossilen abhängigkeiten
sein und in dem sinne sehen wir dass
erneuerbare hier eine antwort auf alles
ist
die hamburger schulbehörde hatte alle
schülerinnen und schüler vom unterricht
befreit für die heutige dämmung bei den
klima streiks hatte ist das nicht
gegeben
das ist sehr wichtig das geld der welt
zeigen putin zeigen das ist okay jetzt
was gerade passiert man sieht einfach
nur wie diese truppen einmarschieren man
sieht die familien die jetzt auseinander
gerissen werden und man sitzt hier und
kann erst mal eigentlich gar nichts
machen was fühlt sich gerade in auch
keine macht ist einfach nur komplett
menschenverachtend und einfach im kampf
gegen uns alle und ich finde dass wir da
auf jeden fall einschreiten müssen
gerade für junge menschen so schien es
bietet die große gemeinsamkeit einen
gewissen halt in diesen schweren tagen
man ist nicht allein für sich allein
fühlt man sich dann unsicher und auch
für leute die sonst nicht so sich stark
machen merken hier alle stehen mit mir
hier und deswegen ist es glaube ich echt
cool
auch in berlin gingen heute wie in
vielen deutschen städten tausende junger
menschen auf die straße es ist ein
aufschrei der jugend den vor allem einer
höheren soll der kriegsjahre in moskau
immer mehr großunternehmen ziehen sich
wegen des krieges aus russland zurück
jetzt auch volkswagen der konzern will
ab sofort keine fahrzeuge mehr nach
russland liefern auch die produktion in
dem land wird eingestellt zuvor hatten
schon andere autobauer wie mercedes benz
und bmw ihre geschäfte in russland
gestoppt
jetzt haben sich auch die ukrainer und
russen doch noch geeinigt auf einen
humanitären korridor beziehungsweise
korridore das sind die letzten meldungen
zum krieg in der ukraine senden wir auch
heute wieder ein zdf spezial gleich im
anschluss an unsere sendung und
jederzeit über die aktuellen
entwicklungen informiert sind sie mit
unserem live blog in der zdf- heute-
jetzt zu corona seit mitternacht gelten
keine länder mehr als hochrisiko gebiete
damit entfällt auch die quarantäne
pflicht für reiserückkehrer das robert
koch institut meldet 210
1673 kroner neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
5649 weniger als vor einer woche
267 todesfälle kamen binnen eines tages
hinzu die sieben tage incident ist
leicht gestiegen auf jetzt
blicken wir nun in den osten australiens
dort kämpfen die menschen weiter gegen
die teilweise schlimmsten überflutungen
in der geschichte des landes weite teile
der bundesstaaten new south wales und
queensland stehen unter wasser die
behörden warnten hunderttausende vor
diesen wassermassen viele mussten ihre
häuser und wohnungen verlassen betroffen
auch teile der millionen metropole steht
nehmen und von dort jetzt normen
odenthal
hier geht es nicht weiter und auf der
anderen seite auch nicht sinnbild einer
sintflut die einfach nicht enden will
der osten australiens geht dem
dauerregen unter das tiefdruckgebiet
kommt nicht von der stelle an der brücke
hier kann man vielleicht am besten
erkennen wie hoch das wasser schon steht
normalerweise sind von der fahrbahn bis
zur wasseroberfläche zwölf meter platz
inzwischen hat sich das wasser die
fahrbahn schon fast komplett geholt kaum
noch land in sicht die ausmaße sind
gigantisch in sidney und umgebung wurden
200.000 menschen aufgefordert ihre
häuser sofort zu verlassen weitere
300.000 sind vorgewarnt
machen sie sich bitte bereit wenn sie
diese warnung haben dann aus der wohnung
einer anordnung zur evakuierung wird
dann kommen sie sofort daraus wir ordnen
das nicht so spaß an wir wollen ihr
leben und das ihrer familie
14 menschen sind tot mehrere werden
vermisst existenzen versinken im wasser
es sind so viele betroffen die häuser
laufen voll die stelle das vieh säuft ab
die ernte ist weg das wasser steht ja
meter hoch meterhoch über den feldern
alles ist weg die sind am ende
vergangenes jahr haben sie von
jahrhundertflut gesprochen jetzt schon
wieder das ist klimawandel das kann
keiner mehr leuten
der werra gamba damit roth aus allen
nähten zu platzen immer wieder müssen
die schleusen geöffnet werden auch diese
wassermassen müssen noch irgendwohin
der internationale sport steht weiter
unter dem eindruck des krieges jetzt
geht es weiter mit ihr sein und die
paralympics in peking werden ab morgen
nun doch ohne die athletinnen und
athleten aus russland und belarus
stattfinden das internationale
paralympische komitee hatte ihre
teilnahme zunächst erlaubt und ein
aufeinandertreffen mit ukrainischen
sportlern in kauf genommen heute in
peking die sportpolitische rolle
rückwärts
die situation im athletendorf drohte zu
eskalieren sie seien mittlerweile
unhaltbar geworden mit diesem
hintergrund die integrität der spiele zu
erhalten die sicherheit aller
teilnehmerinnen zu gewährleisten haben
wir uns entschieden russland und belarus
von der teilnahme auszuschließen ein npc
bella durch damit fort dass sie den
meisten internationalen sportverbänden
das ganze dient ja nicht im ziel den
athleten zu zahlen sondern endlich am
kino lukaschenko die rote karte zu
zeigen das team der ukraine ist mit 20
sportlerinnen angekommen ein wunder
sagen sie china symbol gilt nun auch für
die paralympics der krieg soll bitte
draußen bleiben
und razzia beim dfb rund eine woche
bevor der neue präsident gewählt wird
erschüttern ermittlungen den deutschen
fußball-bund neben der dfb-zentrale
durchsuchten ermittler auch ein wohnhaus
eines ehemaligen funktionärs
markus haben in frankfurt worum geht es
genau
es ist ein neuerlicher dfb skandal der
den propagierten neuanfang für die
nächste woche deutlich in frage stellt
wieder eine razzia wieder durchsuchungen
der staatsanwaltschaft die geht hier
beim dfb quasi ein und aus die neuen
vorwürfe untreue und wohl eine schwarze
kasse einen kommunikationsberater hat
360.000 euro vom dfb kassiert ohne
eindeutige leistungsnachweise die
staatsanwaltschaft spricht von einem
schein vertrag und ermittelt jetzt gegen
diesen berater und gegen den ehemaligen
generalsekretär friedrich co ceos aber
das ist wohl nur die spitze des
eisberges denn auch der jetzige
interviews präsident rainer koch soll
fäden gezogen haben wahrscheinlich kommt
noch viel mehr ans licht vielen dank
markus haben unter dem thema bleiben wir
natürlich dran das wars vom sportbetrieb
vielen dank sven zum wetter vorab im
osten eher trüb im westen sonnig katja
horne vergleich mit den details das
heute journal mit marietta slomka
informiert sie ab 21 uhr 45 uhr das war
es von uns wir sagen danke fürs
zuschauen empfehlen die kollegen vom zdf
spezial die gleich nach dem wetter
beginnen in allen von uns guten abend
[Musik]
guten abend groß waren die unterschiede
auch heute wieder es gab zum teil
strahlenden sonnenschein aber auch nebel
und hochnebelfelder sie lösten sich hier
in mecklenburg vorpommern und schleswig
holstein ganz gut aus aber im nördlichen
brandenburg in berlin und auch entlang
der elbe blieb es den ganzen tag über
trüb und deswegen auch kalt mit nur ein
grad höchsttemperatur deutlich milder
wurde es im süden und dem westen mit 10
bis 14 grad heute nacht gibt es einige
wolkenfelder an den alpen sonst ist es
häufig klar im nordosten aber kommen
schon dichte wolken heran das ist auch
nebel und hochnebel und es kann einzelne
schneefälle auch im erzgebirge geben das
sind so einzelne schneeflocken etwas
schneegriesel oder schnee sterne die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht auf
null grad an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee und bis minus 8 grad am alpenrand
und morgen liegen die temperaturen in
der osthälfte bei 1 bis 6 grad im westen
zwischen sylt und dem bodensee wird es
bei 7 bis 11 grad milder und auch
morgens wieder viel sonnenschein im
westen und im südwesten im osten dagegen
dominieren die dichteren wolken nebel
hochnebel es kann auch noch ein paar
schneefälle in den erzgebirge geben die
sind wir dann am wochenende los im osten
ist es viel kälter und wolkiger im
westen bilder und sonniger genannt